[Music]
we're four days walk from the nearest
road the landscapes vast the wilderness
is almost unlimited the access is by
aircraft on foot or on the right day you
can boat it but it's a challenge in
itself
really we are at the mercy of the
weather and the tides and our day-to-day
life it's difficult living out here but
if you do what's needed and everything
comes together it's a really rewarding
place to be Warwick Mitchell lives in
Fiordland New Zealand's oldest and
largest National Park it covers over
12,000 square kilometres but is home to
only a few dozen people the parks
massive mountain ranch isolates warwick
from civilization living out here like
everywhere you need shelter a good dry
camp we have solar panel for power
lighting and satellite communications we
have a quad bike we have two boats for
fishing and diving and we have the
freezer which keeps our food and our
produce cold
we rely on rainwater for drinking water
so that's not too hard with 7 metres of
rainfall annually we largely live off
the land when you're living off the land
you're really at the mercy of the
weather and the elements so there's
certain times that will allow you to go
out and harvest a deer or catch a fish
capture the menu
[Music]
if you have a down day and the waves are
really good you're more than likely
going to go surfing if the waves aren't
good but the rivers looking nice you
might catch a trout if the waves are
flat for the oceans calm you might go
see fishing if the oceans stormy you
might go up the river for a kayak or go
through the bush and see if you can spot
a deer
[Music]
living in the wilderness doesn't mean
you're living in isolation from people
we certainly couldn't be doing what we
do if it wasn't for that
pilots and our neighbors and our friends
whether it's the harshness of the
environment and being so isolated that
brings people together or the fact that
the people that are willing to travel
this far have like-minded passion for
the environment and the outdoors one
thing's for sure over the years is that
the communities become really tight-knit
can you go ahead and turn this main
switch on and we'll just see if she
wants to work know when things break or
things don't go your way it's always
really important to remember you're in
the green the experiences being out here
and enjoying being out here everything
else is a bonus so you can't get too
serious if one thing breaks I don't know
too many places in the world where you
can stand on a boat looking back and you
can just see ocean leading into forests
leading into massive snow-capped
mountains in Glacier shaped Bay's with
pristine rivers and clear water the
trees are as they were 200 years ago and
the people that I bring out here they
get to experience this nature as it was
and as it should be and we try to keep
the area and the environment pristine in
this little corner of New Zealand
you
[Music]